To move from one activity -
in this case, the MainActivity
in our Sunshine app,
to another, here the DetailActivity -
we call StartActivity.
But note that when using
the StartActivity method,
rather than specifying the class name
of the activity to start directly,
that class name is packaged
explicitly within an Intent.
The basic premise is simple:
Whenever you need your app components
to communicate with each other,
or the system, you use Intents
to identify the target destination.
Starting activities within your app
is the simplest example...
with your Intent explicitly indicating
the target using the context
and a class name of the activity.
Intents that use the name
of the component you're targeting directly
are known as Explicit Intents.